Speaker 1: A very quickly.
I don't want to spend a lot of time on this,
but some people wrote to me again and they
said, What is going on with the N-word being
used by failed former President Donald Trump?
This is starting to get really strange.
I almost think Trump's trying to just appear
to be provocative.
Trump multiple times now has referred to nuclear
or nuclear, depending on your pronunciation
preference as the N-word.
And now he did it again at some kind of event.
I don't know if this is a fund raiser or a
party or what it is.
Trump now saying, Hey, everybody went crazy
when I referred to nuclear as the N-word.
Speaker 3: Take a look.
We have the greatest nuclear force in the
world.
You don't want to do that.
You know the I call it the N-word.
OK?
I said that to a group of people, they should
deal at all.
He said horrible things about the nuclear
war is the only thing the N-word.
And I said, no, the N-word is the nuclear
word of the nuclear word is something that's
not supposed to be discussed.
You know, talk about it.
You don't talk it, then
Speaker 1: why are people even clapping like
it is completely incoherent?
What he's saying and people are clapping because
Trump says you're not supposed to talk about
the nuclear, what
Speaker 3: you see happening in this amazing
country.
He the empowered he's talking about.
Speaker 1: OK, so Trump now is referencing
when he went on Fox News program.
I don't even know what it's called.
It's a program with Stuart Varney.
It's called.
I don't even know what the show is called.
Stuart Varney is program on FOX Business.
And he played the same kind of coy game.
Speaker 4: I hope to God.
You never have to use that because it would
be that would be the tragedy of all tragedies.
But if we didn't have it, we couldn't talk.
But I listen to him constantly using the N-word.
That's the N-word, and he's constantly using
it the nuclear word.
And we never talk it.
We say, Oh, he's a nuclear power.
Speaker 1: What do you guys think this is
about?
Is this some kind of a dog whistle where whites
are making this up, by the way, guys?
Is this a dog whistle where Trump is signaling
to white supremacists?
I can't go around using the real N-word, but
I'm going to say the N-word and pretend I'm
talking about nuclear.
But I'm actually talking about the N-word.
Is is is that is it a dog whistle that only
some people understand?
Is it Trump trying to just be provocative
by using the term N-word, even if it has nothing
to do with the actual N-word?
I don't know what he's trying to do.
It's very, very strange.
One last bonus clip just about how weird things
are that are going on lately.
Here's Trump talking about when he met Matt
Gaetz, his wife.
AD This was over the weekend, I guess, at
Mar a Lago.
It's just all very bizarre.
Speaker 5: And I do remember when they met,
Speaker 3: he came up.
I said, Who the hell is that?
Not that I noticed those things, but I said
it was that I said, Matt, I don't know how
well you get along, but assuming you get along,
that's the one for you.
And I always say, you've come a long way and
there have again, it's a great couple and
we appreciate it and we love you both.
And we're with you all
Speaker 1: the real weekend at Bernie's vibes,
starting to go there at at Mar a Lago, but
very strange.
What's this N-word stuff about, guys?
Let me know.
I really don't understand it.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
This is one of the last times I'm going to
mention this because we're doing the event
in a few days.
Tuesday, April 19, six p.m.
We're doing a town hall event.
Town hall events are where you get to ask
me questions.
You get to berate me for whatever you want
to berate me for its wide open.
This will be streaming live.
So if you want to listen to the town hall,
it'll be live at six p.m. on the Pacman Live
YouTube channel.
That's YouTube dot com slash Pacman life.
It won't be on the regular YouTube channel,
it won't be on Facebook.
It won't be on Twitch.
It will only be at YouTube.com.
Slash Pacman Live Tuesday, April 19th 6:00.
If you want to call in, then it's going to
be via Discord at David Pakman dot com slash
discord if you're not a member.
Everybody is welcome to call in.
However, if you do become a member, we are
going to have a priority path for you to get
on the air for our paid members.
Everybody will get an opportunity, but it'll
be easier if you're a member and you can sign
up at join Pacman dot com.
So that's Tuesday.
But still a full show of stuff coming up for
you today.
The David Pakman Show, of course, depends
on your support through the membership program,
we do an extra show every day for our members.
You can
sign up at join Packman dot com.
We also have the upcoming David Pakman show
Town Hall on Tuesday, April 19th, and members
will get priority access during the town hall,
which is an amazing thing.
But let's not wait.
Let's hear from people right now.
We take calls via Discord on Fridays at David
Pakman dot com slash discord, and we are going
to start today with John from Philly, John
from Philly.
You're on the air.
John, from Philly, please unmute yourself.
You're on the air and you could talk to me
if you unmuted.
And last chance for John from Philly.
Hmm.
Well, that's really too bad, that's not a
particularly auspicious start.
Let's put it that way.